what uh what's the process of
investigation that you can speak to what
are some interesting
um
things you've learned about what it
takes to do great investigations
sure great investigations reveal
something new or bring something to
light so I think what everyone thinks in
terms of Investigations is like a lot of
like you know Googling or like searching
through articles I think uh that's the
first thing you want to get away from
and you want to try to talk to people
doing like the non-obvious things and
just trying to get perspectives that are
Beyond just what is available so a lot
of it's just having conversations is so
enlightening
um both to victims and also obviously
trying to get talk to the people
themselves secondly there's Sometimes
some analysis you can generate that's
meaningful like blockchain evidence so
in the case of safe moon for example uh
going back to that
I found someone's secret account where
they were pumping dumping coins they
were saying things like who sold I'll
I'll you know I'm so mad at the guy who
sold F the guy who sold and you look at
his account he was the guy selling and
it's like that is just that's great
stuff so digging through the blockchain
kind of I've gained some skills there
um and that's kind of this fun I guess I
would say it's this weird Edge I have
for right now because a lot of people
don't know too much about that
um and so I have this weird expertise
that works now I don't think that'll
work forever because I think people will
kind of figure out how to do very
similar analyzes but uh so it's it's
like kind of an interesting Edge right
now that I have so that's like a data
driven investigation but you also do
interviews right yeah definitely and
then also recently I've tried to get
more response speaking to your point
about like as your platform gets bigger
you need more responsibility I've tried
to get much more
um
responsible about like reaching out or
somehow giving the subject some way to
talk because I think in early on I was
such a small channel that hey I if I ask
them they wouldn't answer but B I kind
of felt like I was launching these
videos into the abyss
and when some of my videos had real
traction I was like okay hang on a
second let's double check this let's
triple check it let's try to make sure
um all this stuff is correct and there's
no other side of the story
I'll say this has interesting
implications because for example I
investigated this thing called Genesis
they're a billion dollar crypto lender
and my conclusion was that they were
insolvent
that's a huge accusation so what do you
do well I emailed their press team
everybody I said hey I think you're
insolvent I think you're this I think I
laid out all my accusations and I said
you have till I think 2 p.m the next day
to respond
at 8 AM before I made my video they
announced all their investors that
they're freezing withdrawals they don't
have the money so they front I I don't
know if they saw the inner like I don't
know if they actually saw that email I
don't want to take credit for collapsing
them or whatever but my point is had I
not taken that level of kind of care and
just said hey you're a you're a scammer
your frauds ironically could I have done
more good by allowing people to withdraw
their money early
I made some tweets that people did see
that like some people got their money
out but my YouTube audience is much
larger and could I have helped more
people had I not given them basically
the ability to know what I was going to
produce when I produced it boy your life
is difficult because you can potentially
hurt the company that doesn't deserve it
if you're wrong or you if you're right
and you warn the company you might hurt
the
oh
uh well I'm glad your wife is a
supporter and keeps you strong that's a
tough tough decision
um ultimately I guess you want to err on
the side of the and of the individual
people
of uh the investors and so on but it's
tough It's always a really really tricky
decision to make very tricky
that's so interesting and then
um
the thing I've seen in your interviews I
that I don't remember because I I think
when you I watched you earlier in your
career you were a little bit harsher you
were having you were like trollier
you're having a little more fun sure and
when I've seen you recently you do have
the fun but whenever you interview you
seem respectful like like you you attack
in good faith which is really important
for an interviewer so then people can go
on and actually try to defend themselves
that's really important signal to send
to people because then you're not just
about tearing down you're after like the
you know it's cliche to say but the
truth like you're you're really trying
to actually investigate in good faith
which is great so that signal is out
there so like people like SBF could like
he should he should go on your platform
I think I mean now it's like in full
not just like a half-assed conversation
on Twitter space but in full yeah that's
that's great that that signal is out
there but of course the downside of sort
of as you as you become uh more famous
people might be scared to sort of go on
um but you're you do put that signal
being respectful out there which is
really really important you know it's
interesting
it surprises me I know it surprises
other people because other people have
commented but it consistently surprises
me how many people still talk to me
uh it's and maybe it's because they and
I really do give a good attempt to try
to argue in good faith I try not to just
like load up ad hominems or anything
like that I just try to present the
evidence and let the audience make up
their mind
um
but it surprises me sometimes that
people will just be like yeah they want
to talk they want to talk they want to
talk I think
it's very human in a way and I think
it's like almost
it's almost like good like one of the
things that is always told to everyone
who's going to talk to the cops is like
you should never talk to the cops
whatever
um which is true you shouldn't talk to
the cops because because even if you're
innocent they can use your words they
can twist your words Etc but there's
something that gets lost in that like
almost robotic like you know
self-interest that I think having open
conversations
even if you've done something wrong I
think there's something really
compelling about that that continues to
make people talk in interrogation rooms
in Twitter spaces wherever you are
regardless of whether you totally
shouldn't be talking and I don't want to
downplay that that's actually really
important I mean it's like a lot of
cases get solved a lot of Investigations
go farther because people sort of make
the miscalculation to talk but I think
it's like almost important in a way that
we have that human bias to like
connect in spite of self-interest